[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure and
an honor to be here.
And we all look forward
very much to the discussion
that we are about to have.
Our speaker today is
Mr. Roger Boisjoly.
He tells me that I
should introduce him
by saying that for 27
years, he has been active
in mechanical design and
structural engineering
in the aerospace industry.
He has worked for
some 14 companies,
of which at least one you
must be familiar with.
And he did not mention
this, but I will.
In 1988, the
American Association
for the Advancement
of Science awarded him
the prize for ethical behavior
as a result of his activities
which followed the Challenger
accident that most of you
are familiar with.
He will talk to us about
engineering ethics,
constructive responses
to difficult situations.
And we have asked a number
of friends and colleagues
to comment on his remarks
and to give their--
testify to their
experience, bear witness
with their experiences,
in issues of the sort.
We have three panelists.
Miss Freada Klein
who is the president
of Klein associates,
a consulting
firm which deals with--
which advises corporations on
the ways in which one adjusts,
in an ethical and proper way,
relationships between employees
and employers.
Professor Melcher
who is professor
of electrical engineering
and computer science.
And he has been active in
electrostatics and a number
of other interesting fields.
He has also been active in
worrying about the role--
the connection between
the academic community
and the Strategic
Defense Initiative,
and thinking about this
has brought home to him
a number of questions that
we all need to worry about.
And Professor David Marks, who
is the professor of and head
of the civil engineering
department, and his region--
his area of activity is
environmental engineering
and management and control,
primarily the public sector
thereof, which raises,
again, a substantial number
of interesting
ethical questions.
I think the way to proceed is
going to be for Mr. Boisjoly
to give us his remarks.
We will then let the
panelists make their comments
and then have a
general discussion.
Mr. Boisjoly, we are
honored to hear from you.
BOISJOLY: Thank you very much.
This talk is based
on my 27 years
experience in the aerospace
industry at 14 companies.
I'm going to recommend to you,
some of the methods I used
to secure a productive
and satisfying career.
I will suggest how to select
your entry-level employer,
explain the task of getting
settled in a new position,
and how to recognize and
deal with real organizational
trouble.
I will give you some examples
of my career confrontations
with lessons learned and
summarize with a few challenges
to you.
How to select your
entry-level employer
is what I'll deal with first.
Seek employment
with a company that
has a large commercial
mix of business
rather than a government
dependent military or aerospace
base.
There are two reasons for this.
First, a mixed
commercial business,
even if combined with
some government business,
will provide a
better opportunity
for long-term stability.
And second, the company
is more likely to be
responsive to conduct
business on a higher
ethical plane due to the
inherent commercial marketplace
accountability that exists.
Commercial marketplace
accountability
has the effect of
placing management
at business risk for
future of their company
as opposed to a government
contractor company that
essentially has zero business
risk or accountability,
even if caught conducting
unethical or fraudulent
business practices.
The evidence to
support this condition
abounds in the media with
many examples of wrongdoing
by many of the
government contractors,
without any of them ever losing
their contractor certification
to bid on those contracts.
Their fines after
being caught are
almost laughable if it
weren't for the seriousness
of the situation.
Since they are delivering
faulty hardware
that doesn't come close
to meeting specifications
and are having huge profits
without accountability.
An ideal company has
approximately 1,000 employees
reporting to one general manager
at one physical location.
This number is not
cast in concrete
but is a good starting point.
This size limitation
is very important,
since it determines how well
a company or division can
be managed as well as
its operating philosophy.
Read the book titled
In Search of Excellence
for a detailed rationale of
why this size limitation is
important.
My 27 years experience
mirrors the position
stated in that
book, and I heartily
subscribe to the small
size, family type atmosphere
organization that provides
the best career opportunity
and environment over all others.
Interviews, especially
at the entry level,
seem totally one-sided, with the
company doing its best to sell
itself, and their organization--
that their organization
offers the best opportunity
for a professional career.
They're one-sided simply
because students generally
allow it to become
one-sided for fear
of not obtaining a job and
a good quality interview.
And this is quite normal,
but you have an obligation
to yourself to ascertain
more about the company
than they will just tell you.
You must attempt to find
out about their management
philosophy and
organizational structure,
so you can evaluate if they
match your minimum ideals.
For example, ask to
whom the quality control
manager reports.
Also, ask if they have
an ombudsman program
and to whom that
ombudsman reports.
The answers to
these two questions
alone will provide great
insight to their management
and operating philosophy.
It will not guarantee
anything, but it will
provide significant insight.
For example, if neither
the quality control manager
or the ombudsman reports to the
top executive at that facility,
then this is a red
flag of caution
because this may be a
deliberate management
flaw in the
organization to promote
the ability of other
line organizations
to extract cooperation
with their agenda
by intimidation of
the quality control
manager or the ombudsman.
And I can tell you
as a sidelight,
if the ombudsman reports to the
personnel department, that's
two red flags of caution.
I assure you that this type
of management organization
creates the ideal climate
for unethical misuse of line
organization power to meet the
goals of short-term profits
and delivery schedules, and
keep top management segregated
from the real
day-to-day operations,
but very happy with
the results provided.
Another important
question to ask
is, does a top executive hold
at least a yearly meeting
to give a sort of state of
the company status review
to its employees.
Well-managed companies
generally tend towards this type
of communication from the top.
It is a very motivating time.
And the results are
usually recognized
by these companies that do it.
I believe that the
most important request
you can make during
any interview
is to ask to speak in
private to your future peer
group in the departments
which you are being considered
for employment and ask
the following questions
as a minimum.
What do you like or
dislike about this company?
Would you recommend coming
to work here at this time?
Do you like working
in this department?
Or would you prefer working
in another department?
Is your supervisor and manager a
strong, but supportive and fair
individual?
Are you required to
work excessive overtime
with or without compensation
at the whim of supervision,
whether it is needed or not?
You will be amazed at the candid
answers that you will receive.
But be sure to talk to
more than one person
to minimize the
possibility of talking only
to a disgruntled employee.
Also, be prepared to answer
some questions about why
you are asking such questions.
I hope you have concluded by
now, that all this requires
some detailed preparation
so you can present yourself
in a smooth, relaxed,
and sincere manner.
Practice with your
fellow job-seeking
peers and always remember that
companies are seeking the best
employees for their
organizations,
and you have your
talents to offer
in exchange for a good ethical
work environment and career
opportunity.
I sincerely believe that many
companies have come full circle
and realize that their employees
are their number one asset.
And they've completed
or are in the process
of shedding their
form of business
as usual mode of operation in
favor of organizational changes
which will provide open,
objective discussion
of problems.
Now, that you've had a chance
to get a entry-level position.
Let's talk about
the task of getting
settled in that profession
that you've selected.
Companies generally
use two methods
to introduce you to
their organization.
One is to assign
you to read what
seems to be a never-ending
stack of policies and procedures
manuals.
And the other is to give you a
short synopsis of the contents
of those manuals and assign
an informal mentor who
will help you get acquainted
with their procedures.
If you are unlucky enough
to get the form a method,
then a word of advice
is appropriate,
don't waste your time
reading in detail
because the day-to-day
operations of almost
every company has no
resemblance to what's
written in the manuals.
Be an attentive observer of
who and how things get done,
and take every opportunity
to attend meetings,
and ask to do so if
not invited to do so.
You can assess-- so you can
assess the players quickly.
At first, be happy with
your role as observer,
and be attentive to
who is participating
in the discussions.
Identify the managers and who
is controlling the meeting,
and if the discussions
appear to be
objective with factual depth,
or just bland rhetoric.
It is very important to
assess as quickly as possible,
if meeting content is
almost totally controlled
by management, or if
technical subordinates
are allowed to engage
in wide-open discussion
of problems.
One surefire way to
make this assessment
is to observe the
person with the highest
authority at any meeting.
If that person is usually
quiet until near the end
of the meeting, then it means he
is truly interested in problem
resolution.
But if that person
usually speaks first
about technical
content, then he is
using the meeting for
his own personal agenda,
and little meaningful
problem resolution discussion
will ensue.
Spend as much time as possible
outside your assigned area
talking with people
from other departments,
and soliciting their
help, and offering yours.
Be sincere about
this because it will
become a very important
asset for you in the future.
I use this very method to
develop name, competency,
and productivity recognition
by others, especially those
in management positions.
And this was a key element
for me in any organization,
with the sole exception of
being in the right place,
at the right time,
with the right mentor,
and that never happened to me.
Don't ever be
afraid to speak out
in support of a
technical position
you have confidence with.
But also don't be afraid to
say, I don't know the answer
to that question,
instead of trying
to bluff an answer to, and lose
your precious integrity, which
will result in long-term
damages to your career.
It will take approximately
six to nine months
to feel comfortable
within the organization.
And then it is time to start
the serious documentation
of your work product
by writing memos, which
are carefully prepared to
catch the eye of your peers
and management.
All memos must contain
three basic features.
First, the subject of the memo
must be clear and concise.
It sounds very simple,
but oftentimes, this
is one of the most
brutalized aspect of a memo.
Second, the memo must contain
a complete executive summary
stating the problem,
solution, recommendations,
and a conclusion in a
maximum of one page.
I don't mean executive summary
plus introduction spills over
into second page.
One physical page is the maximum
that an executive summary
should be contained in.
It should never spill
to the second page ever.
Third, the detailed discussion
containing a much expanded
version of the executive summary
with all the supporting data
deemed necessary to complete
the documentation of your work
output.
This memo format
is very important
because it lets you send
it to upper management,
within and outside
your department,
with a high probability
that they will read
the short executive
summary, and the whole memo
if the executive summary
piques their interest.
I highly recommend the method
stated thus far, but only,
only, and I emphasize
only, if you
are genuinely interested
in receiving recognition,
and are willing to participate
in an accelerated and increased
portion of productivity output.
Now, that we're
settled, how do we
go about spotting real and
serious organizational trouble,
and what to do about it?
You will learn from experience
that very few projects run
smooth and
trouble-free, regardless
of the amount of
talent assembled
to solve the problems,
because people always
have different levels of ego,
competence, self-esteem, et
cetera.
I define real trouble as
a recognized deficiency
in a product, which has
a reasonable probability
of causing a serious
problem to the end-user,
but is not acknowledged
by management to be
a serious problem
that needs fixing.
The mode of operation
that usually precedes
this definition is one that
I have already mentioned,
when the person with the
highest level authority
controls the technical
meetings, and also exercises
absolute control on
how presentations
are prepared and presented, both
internally and to customers.
This type of
organizational misconduct
places the technical
professional
in a very difficult position
between the company management
and the customer, especially
when the technical people
are expected to
defend the management
position, whether
technically correct or not.
Another clue to
look for is the lack
of personal recognition
for exceptionally good work
and a high level of productivity
at merit review time.
This is usually a subtle,
but highly visible,
message being sent to you
by someone in management
that you do not fit their
definition of a team player.
If you receive two non-deserved
bad merit reviews in a row,
this is more than
a subtle suggestion
of your fall from favor
with the hierarchy.
This is one of the least
adversarial and most effective
management tools used to
crush a person's ethical fiber
and is used often as
a tool to encourage
people to leave voluntarily.
The most serious trouble of all
comes when meeting schedules
supersedes everything else,
especially the requirements
of safety and quality.
This is the toughest
category of serious trouble
to contest because shipments
produce revenue, which maintain
short-term profits, and keep
executive management very happy
indeed.
Be advised that there is
no way for an individual
to ever win or force
change of operation
in this category of
trouble without committing
sure and swift career
suicide, unless you
are able to gather colleague
support for your position.
If technical support is
received from your colleagues,
then attempt to obtain their
backing and cooperation,
and meet with management
to discuss the problem
and proposed solution.
You have a loyalty
to the company
you work for to
first seek problem
resolutions through your
organizational chain
of command.
Don't ever go outside without
first giving them a chance
to correct the situation.
If management is
not receptive, then
attempt to publish
a position paper
with the support of as many
colleagues as possible,
and send it up through the
management organization.
You may find that when
you put things on paper,
some of that support
will diminish.
If management also
rejects this approach,
it is now becomes
personal decision time,
and three distinct
options exist,
which are most
effectively stated
in Albert Hirschman's
book titled Exit, Voice,
and Loyalty.
At this point of confrontation,
the individual decisions
are tough because your career
and peace of mind are at stake.
I cannot tell you what to
do, but I can assure you
of an intense
struggle from within,
and difficulty with restless
sleep if you are a person
of conscience.
I do have some
advice that should
be followed if you
decide to write memos,
like I did at
Morton-Thiokol in 1985.
You must first gather
all the written evidence
possible in the form of
memos, reports, drawings, et
cetera, to support
your position,
and transport them
to a safe place
away from the
company or your home,
prior to writing
your first memo.
The serious memo writing
can now commence,
and should inform management in
the clear and simple language
about your concerns, so
management cannot, excuse me,
claim a misunderstanding
at a later date.
I was very lucky
at Morton-Thiokol
that my files were not
purged by the company
before I had an
opportunity to give
my information to the
Presidential Commission
investigating the Space
Shuttle Challenger disaster.
I've thought long and
hard about the methods
I used to expose the
truth about Challenger.
And I have concluded that I
would do everything the same,
except I would protect all the
documentation well in advance
to avoid a lack of
evidence at a later date.
Now, I'd like to share some
personal examples of my career
confrontations.
The following examples
are in chronological order
to demonstrate how the
magnitude of confrontations
increase in both severity
and frequency with years
of experience.
In 1960, I was at my first
job at Hamilton Standard
in Broad Brook, Connecticut.
A project engineer was
reviewing a rather extensive set
of gear train actuate
calculations with me.
And I noticed an error
in an equation, right
at the very beginning
of the calculation,
but said nothing,
and let him continue.
As time passed, I could
no longer contain myself,
and I blurted out
that the results
were wrong due to an error at
the beginning of the analysis.
He was shocked and
quickly challenged
me to show him the error.
And he became angry with me.
So I apologized to
him for the delay
in acknowledging that error.
He composed himself
quickly, since he was not
angry for me for
finding the error,
but angry that I took so
long to inform him of it.
We became somewhat friendly
after this encounter.
The lesson I learned
from this was
to never delay bringing
up bad news to anyone
because the delay
causes more discord
and really throws an
immense amount of suspicion
on your integrity.
In 1963, I was at my third job
at Autonetics in California.
I was hired to perform
stress analysis
with the title of
design engineer,
and subsequently attempted
to obtain a transfer
to the official structures
group to enhance my analysis
opportunities and capabilities.
But my supervisor denied
the request to transfer.
Upon hearing of layoffs,
and witnessing those layoffs
taking place at the company
of approximately 40,000 people
at that division at the time,
I immediately sought a position
at another company
because I feared
that my request for transfer
had damaged my relationship
with that supervisor.
I accepted another position
and submitted my resignation,
and my supervisor was shocked.
And he tried very, very
hard to convince me to stay,
but I told him I had already
agreed and gave my word,
and I left.
The lesson I learned was
to always participate
in open discussion
about your position,
especially if you
feel it's in jeopardy.
In the example I just gave,
before accepting other employ,
I was very happy there.
But I thought I didn't stand
a prayer of staying there
with those massive layoffs
that were coming on,
and just don't make the
mistakes that I've made.
In 1965, I found myself at my
sixth job at Hamilton Standard
Aerospace division--
totally different division
and a different
physical location
although it was the
same corporation.
My position was design engineer
on the Apollo Lunar Lander
environmental control system.
And I refused to sign
off on a discrepant part
as I was being pressured by
a project engineer to do so.
A quality control manager had
observed the confrontation.
And he approached me afterwards
with support and the following
advice.
He told me to ask myself
the following question
when faced with a tough decision
of whether a product was
acceptable or not, would you
allow your wife or children
to use the product
without any reservations?
If I could not
answer that question
with an unqualified
yes, he said,
I should not sign off on that
product for others to use.
I have always used this
as a surefire method
to defuse an ethical
dilemma concerning
the safety of a product.
And I've realized
that it is really
a direct application and simple
application of the golden rule.
Do unto others as you would
have them do unto you.
The lesson learned
was to always practice
personal and professional
ethical behavior,
and you'll go far in
your career for doing so.
In the 1967 to '73 time
frame, I was at my eighth job
at a company called
Celesco Industry.
It was formerly a West
Coast Defense division
of Atlantic Research
Corporation that had
been spun off to Susquehanna.
As a senior stress engineer, I
was selected as the engineering
representative to inspect the
assembly of several Athena
missiles at the launchpad
to assure compliance
to structural
design requirements.
During one of my inspections, I
found a payload cable retention
bolt was loaded and bending
across its threads, which
is a no-no, due to improperly
aligned mounting surfaces.
The failure of this bolt
would destroy the nose cone
and ruin all chances for
a successful research
and development flight.
So I reported my concerns
to the project manager
with my recommendation
to replace
the hardware with properly
designed surfaces.
He refused to take action for
fear of delaying the launch.
So I told him that I would call
the Air Force colonel myself
and report my findings.
And he knew I meant it,
so he placed the call.
The Air Force agreed with
me, and immediately obtained
a high priority
work authorization
at a local machine shop.
And the work was completed
during the weekend
without delaying the launch.
The colonel thanked
me, and I eventually
received company support
because the customer was
pleased with my performance.
Another incident on the
same program at a later date
involved a design mistake
in a tongue and groove joint
on a heat shield, which
continually failed in testing.
A customer interface
meeting was convened
to discuss the problem, and
as the discussion continued
for several hours, I discovered
what the cause of the problem
was while tinkering with
several small parts on my lap.
I was confident
with my findings,
and frustrated with
the superficial level
of problem discussion, which
was wasting everyone's time.
And I remember thinking
that no one wanted
to say or do anything
significant because it was
Friday afternoon,
and to bring up
a problem at that late day
would mean we'd probably have
to work through the weekend.
From sheer frustration
about my time
being wasted and
knowing that I was
going to be the one working
the problem anyways,
I spoke up and
interrupted the meeting,
used a simple demonstration
with the parts
to show what was wrong, and
suggested how to fix it.
I was right.
We worked the weekend.
But we fixed the
design, and were back
by testing by midweek,
and it worked just fine.
My immediate supervision was
very pleased with my efforts.
But the chief engineer
was not pleased at all
for me exposing the problem
at the meeting in front
of the customer.
Approximately a year later,
the same chief engineer
tried in vain to
order me to give
a slanted technical
presentation to the Air Force
on the same missile structure.
I refused to do so.
And the chief engineer gave the
presentation himself, with me
in the room, knowing
full well that if I
was asked any detailed
questions about my analysis,
that I would have shot
him down in flames.
I have never seen anybody
sweat so much in all my life
as that man did during
his presentation.
I'm positive that that
confrontation and refusal
to make that
presentation cost me
a supervisor's position
at a later date
because he knew he
could not manipulate me
as he was accustomed
to doing with others.
The lessons learned from
these experiences at Celesco
was the opportunity to
practice past lessons learned
and to reinforce my ethical
professional behavior.
In 1977, I found
myself at my 11th job
at Garrett AiResearch
in Torrance, California.
While working as a contract
engineer-- and some of you
may know that term
as a job shopper,
where a company
actually shops you
in to a parent company that
needs some temporary expert
help.
While going in there
as a contract engineer,
I discovered after
approximately one
month that a structural
beam designed
to support a 50,000
pound heat exchanger
would fail in
lateral instability
if loaded during assembly,
and could cause loss of life
to those that were
involved in the assembling.
I was aware that the equipment
had been designed and analyzed
during the preceding
1 and 1/2 years,
by engineers with
advanced degrees,
and was in the final
detail drawing phase
prior to fabrication.
I told my supervisor about my
analysis predicting failure,
but he was somewhat skeptical.
And so I thought, oh,
no, here I go again--
another confrontation.
I arrived for work the
next day, and had barely
sat down at my desk,
when my supervisor asked
me to go with him to the
chief engineer's office.
I was surprised and,
initially, pleased to find that
the prior evening, they had
built a balsa wood beam, scale
model beam, but
disappointed to learn
that its purpose was to prove
me, the outsider, wrong.
We loaded the beam in
the lab and plotted
deflection versus load
curves as the beam
was incrementally loaded.
And as soon as the
critical load was reached,
the beam started to roll
and deflect laterally--
much to the astonishment of my
supervisor and chief engineer.
They quickly asked me
for my recommendations
for fixing the beam.
And I responded
the fix was simply
to place a closure plate on
the open side of the beam
on the compression side.
And this would prevent the
lateral instability action
from occurring.
A strip of balsa wood
simulating that closure plate
was glued in place
and allowed to dry.
The beam was again loaded
in the same load sequence
as before to approximately
twice the load,
without any signs of
lateral instability.
I was thanked for finding
and correcting the problem
and, about a week
later, offered a chance
to go work direct for
Garrett Corporation
after my contract expired
with the job shop.
The offer of direct
employment is
very significant to this
example in experience,
since the engineering department
was primarily composed of PhDs,
with only a few holding master's
degrees, and to my knowledge,
no one in the
engineering department
had a Bachelor of
Science degree.
When I went to personnel
with my completed application
form and resume and asked to
be processed into the company,
the man became very
upset about three things.
First, according to him,
I had held 10 jobs before,
and he called me a
transient employee.
Second, he scoffed
at me for having
a Bachelor of Science degree.
And third, there was no
outstanding requisition
in the engineering
department for a new hire.
He told me point-blank that
had I applied for employment
through the front
door, my resume
would have been
swiftly discarded
without any chance of
getting an interview.
At that point, I began to
resent his attitude towards me,
and told him to either
process me in, or I would--
directly, or I would return
to the chief engineer,
and tell him he was abusing me.
And since he didn't
want-- and I assumed,
he didn't want me to do that.
After my statement, he
never spoke another word.
And I probably hold the
record for the shortest time
to process a new hire
into Garrett Corporation.
Lessons learned
from this action was
that the good guys do
win, occasionally, when
managers have the courage to
listen and act upon the facts.
And they did.
Even though they were
trying to prove me wrong,
they at least listened,
and took the time
to find out if there
was something wrong.
And the other
lesson I learned is
job shopping is an absolutely
fantastic way to find a job.
But you can only do that after
you have about five years
experience, unfortunately.
In July 1980, I found myself
at my 14th and planned
last industrial job
at Morton-Thiokol.
This was planned to be
my retirement position,
since we moved to a
beautiful, but rather remote,
area of northern Utah.
If you didn't work for
Thiokol in engineering,
you didn't work at all.
It was that simple.
The major point I
want to convey to you
is my conduct on the job,
predating my deep involvement
with the escalation
of the space shuttle
booster joint O-ring problems.
I conducted myself as I had
always done in the past.
And I soon found myself involved
in many of Thiokol's problems,
both on and off the
shuttle program.
I talked with many people
about known problems,
and provided recommendations
for hardware modifications,
process changes, quality
inspection techniques,
analysis methods, and so forth.
But I met with totally
unexpected resistance,
and was told straight out,
that they all knew best
how to do things, since
they had been doing
it the same way for 20 years.
I sometimes replied
from pure frustration
that their methods
were based on two years
experience multiplied
10 times, and that they
were 20 years behind the rest
of the industrialized world.
Since no one will listen to
my verbal recommendations,
I started writing memos, and
followed the same procedures
I have already outlined for you.
I soon became recognized
by management as a doer,
and became somewhat of a
resident expert on fasteners,
material selection, ground
support equipment, and failure
analysis.
So managers outside
the shuttle program
sought my help with
their problems.
My relationship within
the shuttle program
still remained
somewhat adversarial,
especially with the director
of the engineering department.
I had gone to that
director many, many times
with good recommendations,
which he acknowledged as good,
but then he always took
the business as usual side
against me.
Approximately 3 and 1/2 years
into that mode of operation,
I was given a promotion to
project engineering manager
on the shuttle booster
case structure.
This is very
significant because I
leaped over several
supervisors who had been
with Thiokol over 20 years.
And it demonstrates that the
principles of professionalism
and ethical conduct that
I've been explaining to you
can indeed be rewarded.
I hope this mix of my
personal experiences
demonstrates to all of you,
both within and outside
of engineering, that
a rewarding career is
possible to attain
within the framework
of ethical
professionalism, even when
employed by organizations
that conduct themselves
in a somewhat unethical manner.
Remember, as long as management
can use your expertise,
and still control
their overall agenda,
there is little danger
of serious retribution,
unless you pin them
in a corner like I
did during the
Challenger investigation.
I also hope you realize that
all your future decisions will
primarily be based
upon the character
of your previous decisions
on small and relatively
unimportant matters during
your careers up to that point.
By way of example, and
with absolutely no intent
towards malice, I
wasn't surprised
when the vice president of
engineering at Morton-Thiokol
capitulated to the general
manager's directive
to take off his engineering hat
and put on his management hat
at the meeting prior to
the Challenger launch.
I had observed this man
in several different
organizational positions
for 5 and 1/2 years
conduct himself in a
manner to always side
with the business as usual
management philosophy.
I wasn't surprised.
But I sure as hell
was angry with him
for not standing up for what he
knew was technically correct,
as evidenced by his own
conclusions and recommendations
chart that he presented in the
first part of that telecon.
My closing remarks
are very simple.
I implore all of you who are
pursuing engineering careers,
to please set a goal,
and take, and pass
the engineering in training
exam prior to graduation.
Then after five years of
engineering experience,
take the P exam and become a
licensed professional engineer,
whether your chosen
field requires it or not.
I do not say these
things lightly.
I did it the hard way.
30 years out of
school last October,
I took the EIT exam on Thursday,
and the P exam on Friday.
And if I can do it,
and I passed them,
at this institution with
the quality of education
you are getting, it ought to be
a piece of cake for you people.
Join and become an
active participant
in a professional society,
and start a movement
to change the societies towards
support for their members,
as opposed to
supporting the industry
agenda of using employees
as a renewable resource.
Please don't join the
business as usual gang.
And always remember,
you have three choices--
exit, voice, and loyalty.
But I hope you won't
subjectively choose loyalty
to preserve your status quo.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
MODERATOR: OK, we'll
have brief remarks
from each of the
panelists, and then we'll
have open discussion.
You'll notice there's--
there are mics on the floor.
Our first speaker
will be Freada Klein.
KLEIN: I want to comment
on a few of the things
that Roger talked
about in terms of how
to evaluate a company's
ethical practices, approaches
to ethical issues.
I think he focused
on issues of--
related to safety,
related to health,
related to possible dire
consequences for the end-user.
I think there are also other
kinds of ethical dilemmas
that arise in day-to-day
work lives of scientists
and engineers.
Some of those have to do with
how employees are treated
and how employees treat
each other as well.
There are two categories
of ethical issues
that I think are
important to distinguish.
One is ethical issues which
are those of omission, where
information is left
out, or where people,
or where groups are excluded.
And the other would
be ethical issues
which are [? commission, ?]
where there are actual fraud
or problems committed.
When looking at a company,
I think Roger's point
about looking at where
the QC manager reports,
and whether or not there's
a ombuds is very important,
and where they report.
There ought to, also, be an
array of complaint mechanisms.
There ought to be formal
complaint mechanisms that
have a peer review component.
And there ought to be informal
complaint structures that
assure confidentiality.
I think it's also worth
asking about the folklore.
What are people rewarded
for in that organization?
Who are the heroes?
Who are the heroines?
What are the heroic
acts in recent memory
in the organization?
Will tell you a lot
about what's valued--
if there's an open door
policy, for example.
Many IBM employees will tell
you that the open door hits you
in the rear on the way out.
One local high tech
company has a phrase well
known amongst its
employees called
CLMs, Career Limiting Moves.
Any place has part of
an informal culture that
will tell you about its values.
And those are worth finding
out before signing on.
MODERATOR: Thank you
very much, Freada.
Jim, would you like to speak?
Jim Melcher from
electrical engineering.
MELCHER: Yes, I'm not sure
I have so much in mind
here, giving any
kind of presentation,
so much as asking
some questions.
I had the good fortune yesterday
of spending a couple of hours
in Carolyn's home with Roger.
And I'd like to, I think, maybe
get some reactions from you
on some points.
One of these has to do with
the continued theme that
came across of your pride,
and your professionalism,
your ability to be
a good engineer.
Let me put this in our context.
In this room, in
a faculty meeting
last spring, I guess, now,
we had a wide ranging debate
on the subject of pass-fail.
And you could imagine, this is
a grading system for freshmen.
And it has all sorts
of sides to it,
but you'd find that perhaps half
of the engineering community
was very much in favor
of seeing it dropped.
They regarded it as a
mechanism of compromising
the expertise of our students.
Now, out of that, I would gather
they probably didn't succeed,
really, in making their point.
But that the point was, as I saw
it, that if a person were going
to take a strong position,
as you have many times,
it had to be based on being
very good at what you did.
You, I gather, feel
somewhat along those lines?
BOISJOLY: I think so.
And I-- I guess, the best
thing I can use as an example--
when I filed my lawsuits
against Morton-Thiokol,
they came down on
me very, very hard,
trying to discredit me
in every possible manner
that you can imagine.
And my simple answer
to some of the things,
to counter their whole
activity, was simply
to say that it must be a
horrible reflection on them
because I was within
$1,000 dollars of doubling
my salary between 1980
and the summer of 1986.
And so I rested my case.
I said, if I was
a lousy engineer,
a disgruntled engineer,
a know-nothing engineer,
then what does that make
them for doubling my salary?
And I also have
to add to that, I
went through school with a solid
C, not that I'm proud of that.
If I had to do it
all over again,
I'd do it much differently.
But I had a very high
level of interest
in playing tennis, skiing,
and playing hockey.
And I did do my very best
to keep my grades going.
But I did not hit my stride
and hit the Dean's List
until my senior year.
And as a result,
when you've already
had two years of
solid C work, it's
very hard to pick up
your grade point average.
And I probably
wouldn't have been
allowed in most
universities today,
if I'd done that same
type of thing today.
But it doesn't-- the
grades are not in--
I address this relative to
your pass-fail comments.
The grades don't
necessarily mean you're
going to be a good engineer.
Grades don't
necessarily mean you're
going to be a person of
integrity, to speak up,
and do what's right.
And I use myself as the example.
I have had no
trouble whatsoever.
I graduated from Lowell
Technological Institute,
had 168 credit hours
of course study,
and where most of my
fellow students coming out
of the other universities
had between 125 and 135.
And I've never had any
problem whatsoever facing
up and matching up across
the industry with anybody.
And I'll tell you
straight out, there's
a lot of theoretical
stuff I can't solve.
But I let the guys
with the PhDs do that.
There's a lot of
things they can't
do in putting a product out the
door either, but I can do that.
So together, we can put
out a heck of a product.
And that's what it really takes.
It takes both types of people
to really integrate, and make
a company go, and put
out a fantastic product.
MELCHER: Let me try
and get a bit more
of the sharing of
the experiences
you've been through,
maybe following
a different direction.
You perhaps could
make an analogy
to some of the
situations that you've
had with something I saw on
60 Minutes this last Sunday.
Some of you may have seen this.
They were interviewing people
whose children had essentially
drowned, and then
recovered because doctors
had done a little
bit too good a job,
and then been permanently
unable to function.
And they were interviewing
a couple of the mothers who
were in crucial roles in this.
And looking back,
these were mothers
who blamed, in a way, the
doctor for having kept
their child alive when, in
retrospect, they would have
preferred, really,
albeit a wrenching thing,
that the child had
been allowed to die.
Now, we make it sound as
though this decision process--
for example, the one you went
through in only a few days
around the Challenger incident--
was a very logical progression.
And I would imagine that there
are events in there where you
were reacting, just reacting.
That you were drawing upon
these previous experiences,
you mentioned, but--
and your religion, your ethical
view of things, which I wish we
could find some way for
you to share with us more.
But that there were also
moments, contemplated moments,
when probably you realized
what the consequences were.
Consequences, again, that aren't
as black and white as we've
been talking about.
Consequences of walking
the halls in your company
and finding that
there were people
who wouldn't speak to you.
The man was the mayor
of a small community.
And in fact, found
that he was essentially
shunned, in the Mormon
sense, by the community.
These are very personal things.
And there must have been some
point, as this thing began
to evolve, that you contemplated
what you were getting into,
and thought about ways that
you could keep your own values,
and deal with this, and then
took the course you did.
Is that true?
BOISJOLY: Yeah, but
it probably didn't
happen as soon in the process
as you might have thought.
What happened was, from
my past experiences,
and that's why I emphasized
it in the previous remarks,
I was the sum total of how
I acted up to that point.
And it was just natural
for me to continue
to do what I had always done.
And I did not think of
anything up until the point
that I got the vilest
looks that you can imagine
from the general managers--
a general manager
and his associate,
but particularly
the general manager.
And myself and Arnie
Thompson compared
those looks afterwards.
And those are the looks we
decided you get just prior
to being fired.
Now, Arnie was quiet, and
I was quiet at that point
because there was no way that
we could interject ourselves
into that management
meeting in the [? caucus. ?]
So that's the first
little indication.
The next major
thing that happened,
we just went on
the [? failure ?]
investigation team.
And we're doing our
very best to find out
what happened, and
do the very best
to participate in the redesign.
But the night
before we were going
to testify to the Presidential
Commission in closed doors
was the heighth of
the whole thing, when
I realized that I was
about to place myself
right up to my
nostrils in quicksand
because I had written
in my notebook
a whole summary of things
that I was going to relate
to the Presidential Commission.
And at the end of that, I
said something to the effect--
and this is in the
National Archives.
And it is in public
record, but I
have to paraphrase
'cause I haven't
looked at it for a long time.
It said something to
the effect that I hope
and pray that what
I'm about to do
is not going to ruin my career,
my lifestyle, and my family,
and then signed
it, and dated it.
And so that's the first
time, right there,
that I knew I was
about to plunge myself
into a potential very
high retribution area.
But I still went
ahead and did it.
And even afterwards, even with
the anguish from management
received on the plane back
to the Marshall Space Flight
Center, I still
felt, even with that,
that I still had a chance to
participate because I was being
told I was going
to have that chance
to participate in a redesign.
I was very naive, but I truly
believed it in all my heart.
And I felt that, oh.
I may have cost myself a raise.
Or I may cost myself
something here or there.
It didn't matter, as long
as I was able to participate
in fixing the problem.
I was very happy
with what I had done.
And I'd do it again.
And then, of course,
later on, I found out
that that was not
to be the case.
They had actually
given the official word
behind my back to keep
me isolated from Morton--
from the customer and
the redesign effort
although I was a technical
participator in giving
information into the system.
They were never telling
me where it went.
They changed it sometimes
without my knowledge.
They were holding meetings
that I didn't know occurred.
And I got zero feedback.
So they did, in
fact, isolate me.
And when I discovered
that, I realized
just how deep quicksand I
was in at that point in time.
And then in May, myself,
and the rest of us
who called ourselves,
at that time,
the five lepers because
of the ostracization
that we were getting on
the inside of the company.
Like he mentioned, people
not facing us as we
were walking down the corridors,
and other such things.
We tried to still
turn things around,
internal to Morton-Thiokol,
because the morale
was at the basement level
because the guys that
had made the decision were
still in the same management
organizational positions
that they were in when
they made that decision.
And so we asked for a
meeting with the CEO,
the president of the shuttle
program at that time,
and the president of
the aerospace operations
of that company.
And we failed.
We basically failed.
And then that was another stake,
if you will, driven in to me
at that time because
the CEO turned to me.
He was this close.
And after my remarks,
he said, son,
you're never going to get
very far in this company
with that kind of attitude.
And all we went to
do was to tell him
that his company was crumbling
around his shoulders.
And he didn't even know it
because they never took time
to go down at the employee
level and find out
how bad things were.
And that's all we
were trying to do,
and yet, that's the
kind of response we got.
At that point in time,
I felt, it's all over.
And it was just about
a month after that,
that it was indeed all over.
MELCHER: Well, one thing that
came through in your talk
was the loyalty you
felt toward, apparently,
many of the companies,
most of the companies
that you were with.
I'm wondering if, in fact,
I'm reading something
into your statement
in having the feeling
that you probably were
motivated by having
the feeling you were doing the
best thing by your company.
BOISJOLY: I felt that
night, I felt after it,
I still feel today, with every
fiber of life in my body,
that I was a more loyal employee
at Morton-Thiokol and other
places for doing
what I had done,
then employees who would turn
their back and say nothing.
That case about
the missile, there
were many cases on
that missile that
were too numerous to mention.
All the time, I did the
same types of things.
And I had a very
fruitful career,
albeit adversarial
at some times,
but it was fruitful nonetheless.
And I do, I feel that
you have an obligation
to be loyal to your
organizational chain
of command, and
first approach them.
First, orally, then in
writing, before you ever even
think about going outside.
And if you don't do that,
you deserve everything
you get as an
individual for going
outside first because you did
not give them the opportunity.
You owe that company
that loyalty.
And I have always
felt that, even
before I read about all
this whistle-blowing stuff.
And I've always felt
that in my heart.
I didn't know that I was doing
things right down the line
like they're
supposed to be done.
I just felt that that's
the way to do it.
MELCHER: Thank you.
MODERATOR: Dave Marks,
[? would you ?] [? like to-- ?]
Dave Marks from
civil engineering.
MARKS: I have
questions for you too.
It's better to ask
questions than to receive.
But it seems to me that the
civil engineers are a bit
different than other engineers.
Basic definition that I've
heard of civil engineers
is they build very large
things that don't move,
and you want to make sure
that they don't move,
implying safety considerations.
And I've rarely seen
a civil engineer
who gets into trouble
because he brings up
a safety consideration.
I mean, the earliest
part of our training
is watching a film loop
of the Tacoma Narrows
Bridge, the Galloping Gertie.
And they show that to
you over, over again.
And the message is don't
let this happen to you.
But in fact, people who
work in the public sector,
or in public sector engineering
run into different types
of ethical issues.
And the basic ethical issues
are really relate to values
because very often
you are, in fact,
society's engineers and society
does not speak with one voice.
Society speaks in a
very confusing way.
And there are major
parts of society
that, in fact, don't
have a voice at all.
And the questions
that I'll raise to you
have to do between this
dichotomy between these things,
I mean, particularly in
the environmental area.
Or for instance, take the
transportation area, and all
of our young engineers
can design the bridges
and pavements of an
interstate highway system,
yet has anybody ever
asked about the decision
for an interstate
highway system,
and how that has changed
the basic fabric of America?
I mean, it really has.
When we look at the Superfund
cleanup, which is, of course,
tremendously interest to us.
No one wants to see hazardous
and toxic wastes around.
In fact, we have
been unable, so far,
to define how clean is clean.
We simply don't have the
scientific knowledge.
Nonetheless, we can't wait
until we have that knowledge
to continue.
And so we have tried to bring
a veneer of quantification in.
Something is clean,
and something
that's slightly larger
than that is not clean.
We have a whole
ethic built up now
of doing environmental impact
statements for new procedures,
which somehow is supposed to
represent a valid decision
process, yet a
young employee might
question how well it does.
We have the growing of
environmental terrorists, who
have gotten tired of the way
environmental things are going,
and are simply taking
matters into their own hands,
much in the same way of
animal rights activists.
So I guess the two questions I
would ask you in this context,
and really come back to
your question, this is--
is how does one deal in
this dichotomy of lining up
your own personal values
with society's values,
when they're not
well-represented?
And the second question is, I
would come back to a question
that you raised, what
is the definition
of a rewarding career, when
technical analysis, and being
good in technical analysis on
certain parts of the problem,
often does not address
the whole problem?
BOISJOLY: Well,
OK, first, let me
have a little preamble to the
difference between your area
and the area that
I functioned in.
We have a awful
paradox that exists
in this country at this time.
The people who build
our bridges, our roads,
and our buildings are
the civil engineers
who are licensed engineers.
They have a code of ethics.
They have backing.
They have all the things that
we don't have in the industry
that I was in.
The people that build
your automobiles that
go over those roads,
the planes that you
fly in on a daily basis,
which I was involved in,
the missiles, and the
spacecraft are not
licensed people by and large.
You don't have to be,
and so most aren't.
Right there is part
of the root cause
of why I suggest everybody to
become licensed, whether it's
required or not,
because I firmly believe
that you could pull that in.
As far as a rewarding
career is concerned,
I defined my career
as rewarding because I
was able to make a lot
of corrective actions.
I was able to earn
a very good living.
I was very able
and willing to tell
them to stick it in their
ear when it became an impasse
and leave.
Sometimes I changed-- it
was a personal decision that
had nothing to do with the job.
But I felt I had
the opportunity,
in a general sense, in
a high sense, actually,
in the 27 years, to participate
in a reasonably high level
of engineering activity, and
to do the very best I could,
whether they wanted me to
participate in that manner
or not.
And so for me, by my
personal definition,
I was allowed to do
most of the things
that I was able to do well
because I forced the issue
to do it that way.
I often found myself
wandering in the shop,
often found myself wandering
out in the test lab,
often found myself in
places where people like
me don't normally
go, and so I made
it rewarding in the sense that
I did those types of things.
And that's one of the reasons
I recommended to students
to do the same types
of things because you
can get the whole circle
closed of experience.
You get to, not only look
at the specifications,
design, and analyze, test,
go out in shop see it built,
and then follow up
with the customer.
But if you only focus
on the one area,
you don't get that satisfaction,
that feedback loop,
and that next step of
experience to carry
on to the next place
or the next project.
And so that's how I define
the rewarding career.
Now, the first part
of your question,
you'll have to repeat for me.
But I'm not sure, I have to--
I can grasp the
total significance
what you were asking.
MARKS: I guess once
one moves beyond safety
and into another set of values.
For instance, there are
engineers who work on--
BOISJOLY: Oh, OK.
MARKS: --who work on
transportation systems
and, technically,
design them very well.
But in fact, they're not--
they're-- in the process,
they're changing the basic
fabric of America.
Engineers who are working on
environmental impact statements
doing wonderful
models of groundwater,
but, in fact, missing
other parts of the problem
because one can't
do analysis on that.
There are major
non-technical value issues.
I've seen major reservoir
systems designed
in developing
countries, which will
involve moving
millions of people
just to build the reservoirs.
And these people at the lowest
economic level, and they will--
their complete societal
fabric will be disrupted.
No one speaks for those people.
And to a certain extent,
a young engineer,
were he to try and
speak for those people,
or to address those large
issues, and has no form,
has no ability,
it's not part of--
according to people, it's
not part of engineering.
There's no way to
make that argument.
So how does one work in
a situation like that?
Ha, gingerly.
[LAUGHTER]
BOISJOLY: I honestly don't know.
It's like you say, there are no
mechanisms for that to occur.
And even if there
was a tiny mechanism,
it's not a significant
mechanism for the big picture
to allow it to occur.
You end up becoming a
majority of one, usually.
I don't know how to
answer that question.
MARKS: Do you think
that young engineers,
that there's something missing
in their educational process
that makes them afraid to
stand up in tough situations?
Or is it a sense of values?
I mean, why is it that you had
bosses who, in fact, wanted
to cut the line?
Who wanted-- who knew
something was wrong,
but wanted to cover it up?
Is that an educational problem?
Or is it something about how
people move up in systems?
BOISJOLY: I think it's
an educational problem,
but not in the sense
that you view it.
It's not what you're taught, but
what the people have observed.
Our government and our companies
have done a marvelous job
in this country of making sure
that everybody in this country
knows that when you stand
up for a cause that's right,
you're going to get creamed.
And they may-- that's
the first thing they do.
If you think back, you think
back in every visible thing
that you've read
about in recent times,
and not one company
or one agency
has ever addressed the issue
for which has been brought out.
They've always
addressed the person,
and have absolutely
decimated the person,
and never discussed the issue.
And so the message comes home,
just by reading about it,
that you're going to pay a
very bad price in the norm,
if you go and do
something like this.
And so it becomes a focal
point in many people's lives.
My boss, and Arnie Thompson's
boss was the same man,
he is a registered
professional engineer.
He sat in those meetings.
He went to Washington and heard
the Presidential Commission
hearings along with us.
He never said a word in the
meetings before the launch.
He never said a word to the
Presidential Commission ever.
If I had had a license,
I think, and I hoped,
I would have gone a step
further and threatened them
with my code of ethics.
And that's one of the reasons
I'm advising and hoping
that the young people will
pick me up on my challenge,
is so they can bring that code
of ethics into the management
however, side-- by the side
or back door, it's done.
Maybe they'll listen.
I don't know that they
will, but maybe they will.
And I have to tell you, I
knew all of these gentlemen
in that meeting prior to this.
I've had workings with
them for 5 and 1/2 years.
And I have no doubt that when
the general manager said,
about halfway
through that caucus,
am I the only one
that wants to fly?
I have no doubt in my mind that
if any of the three managers
had said, I don't
want to fly, that he
would have folded his briefcase,
and packed it in, and gone
home.
No doubt in my mind.
He was looking for
support from those guys.
Now that you're on quote,
"the enemy's side,"
you've taken the other side.
I don't understand.
My colleagues would
say the same thing.
What's happened?
And the only thing
we've ever been
able to conclude
amongst ourselves
was, after attaining this
level, you have to protect it.
Well, I was promoted to product
engineering manager at Thiokol,
but I didn't tell you
in my short presentation
that after 13
months, I gave it up.
I could no longer
exist in that--
I don't know the word--
awful organization.
I mean, they knew nothing
about how to manage people.
They could care less
about how it was done,
and I didn't want
to be a part of it.
So I went down as a
technical specialist
to the manager of
applied mechanics
because I felt I could help the
program the most, the company
the most, and have the
most satisfaction in my job
instead of just doing
this mediocre crap
day after day after day.
And so I gave up a
managerial position.
And people around
me were shocked.
They said, do you
realize what you've done?
I used to have a ceiling of
$75,000, and when I did that,
I lost a substantial
amount of ceiling.
I didn't care.
I wanted day to
day satisfaction.
I wanted to do
something in my job,
but that doesn't make me a hero.
It just makes me kind of
unique, I guess, in one respect
because most people
don't think that way.
After you get a
management position,
you're going to preserve
it at all costs.
And I didn't do that.
And I-- there were
other people that did
the same types of thing too.
I'm not unique in that respect.
I've seen other people do it.
But by and large, when a person
has attained a certain level,
they're first and foremost
priority become preservation.
I've seen it in the 27 years.
I can't believe it.
I can't explain why,
but that happens.
MODERATOR: Well, I think
we're ready to open
the floor for questions.
So if you-- those of
you with questions
will go to the
microphone, then we
can have your questions
recorded on our video tape.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
meeting with the Air Force,
I think it was, at
which your manager gave
the slanted presentation.
And you sat in silence.
I thought you
didn't say anything
to contradict what he said.
I would imagine that the Air
Force people there, interpreted
your presence, at least, as
implicit support for what
your manager was saying.
Is that true?
BOISJOLY: Well, let me tell
you, it really, in all honesty,
didn't matter what he said
because the part had already
been designed as
a physical part.
It had already been
tested as a physical part.
It worked just fine,
but he was trying
to puff up a certain section
of an analysis conclusion
that just wasn't so.
And he wanted me to do that, OK?
And so I let him do his thing,
but I would have shot him down.
But regardless of
what he said, he
wasn't going to change the
fact that the part was good.
The design had already
been proven in test,
and had already been installed,
and was going to be used.
And so this wasn't a threat.
This was an issue between him
forcing me to do something
that I knew was wrong,
and I wouldn't do it,
and the outcome
was-- absolutely, had
nothing to do with [INAUDIBLE].
MODERATOR: Excuse me, are
you talking about the--
his earlier event that worked
out well in the long run?
Or are you talking
about the telecom
the night before the
Challenger disaster?
AUDIENCE: No, he got it right.
BOISJOLY: No, yeah, you talk--
I know what you're--
you're talking about the
analysis presentation.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
if you're satisfied,
looking back on that with--
from a ethical point of view
with your response to that.
I mean, silence, I
mean, sitting and saying
nothing that could be considered
deceiving in some way.
I was--
BOISJOLY: Well, keep in mind
though, as an individual--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I--
I know.
BOISJOLY: It doesn't make
a whole lot of sense to me,
and maybe I'm wrong, but to me,
it doesn't make a lot of sense,
to speak up and serve yourself
up as a sacrificial lamb,
if you don't have even a tiny,
tiny chance of making a change
or effecting a change.
And if it's not going to
result in any harm downstream
or make any difference,
what's the point?
AUDIENCE: OK, so there was-
BOISJOLY: Now, when it did--
now, if it had been a
different circumstance,
and something was on
the verge of failing,
ho ho, he would not have
given that presentation,
I assure you.
I would have told
him I was going
to get that presentation
like he wanted,
and then proceeded to
give it the way I wanted.
AUDIENCE: Good evening,
I'm registered in Canada
as a professional engineer.
And I haven't bothered to
transfer my registration down
here, largely because
I see that the profile
of professional engineer
in the United States
just hasn't attained the status
of the Canadian professional
engineer.
I was wondering, you--
I fully agree with
you that registering
is a darn good thing to do.
But my question is,
what do you suppose
we can do as engineers
to raise the profile
of the professional, the
registered professional?
BOISJOLY: I think
they're starting
to do just that in the NSPE.
And I think you're
right, they kind of
went along at a mediocre
level for years.
And I think that
they are starting
to come to grips with that.
I think some of the
professional societies
or the technical
societies are really
where it needs to start to take
place and feed into the NSPE.
The technical societies
have got to stop
serving the industry and
the underpinning resources
they get from industry, and
start to serve their members.
And I think you're going to
see a chain reaction spill over
into the professional
side through the NSPE.
But I saw the NSPE as a very
passive organization years ago,
and I see it as a much
more productive and active
organization today.
For instance, I met a
colleague in Missouri
who was on the board at
Missouri when the Hyatt Regency
failure occurred.
And they actually
pursued that prosecution
of that firm and that engineers
for blatant screw ups.
I mean, it was--
freshmen would not have
designed those pins the way
that pin was designed.
And they've lost their license.
And I'll tell you, he told
me, he took tremendous flack
through the profession
for doing what
he did because he was the
president of the Missouri Board
at that time.
And that's an indication
that it's started.
Also, the other
indication it's started,
and it's starting really
in the civil arena.
And it's because the
registration is the strongest
in the civil arena.
And in the civil
arena, they've put
out a product called Quality
in the Constructed Project.
It's a manual.
And it is currently
in practice right now
being used under actual
conditions for review
and comment.
And it is due to end, perhaps
at the end of this year,
and then they will
update that, and expand,
and put more manuals in.
But that is a
wonderful step and that
is feeding in through the NSPE.
And I think that's
going to go a long way
to address the past moderation
that was in that group.
And the civils are
taking the lead position,
no question about it.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
just make a comment,
and ask you to comment on it.
But what I gathered
from your-- what
you said was the conclusion
that one could come to
is that the goals
of the engineer
and the goals of the
managers are not the same.
And that's why there is
this is this constant--
I mean, the picture that
I drew of your accounts,
not only here, but also when
you spoke of it five years ago,
was that there was an
adversarial relationship
between managers and engineers.
The reason why that's
interesting is because this
point was made, actually,
[? by Thorstein ?] [? Veblen ?]
in [? 1920 ?] in a very
interesting [? monograph ?]
called The [? Engineer ?]
and [? the ?] [? Price ?]
[? System, ?] in which he
pointed out that the goals
of management were
basically bottom line goals,
whereas the goals of
engineers were efficient.
And it seems to me
that nothing has
changed in the last 70 years.
And I guess what I want to ask
you is [? assume ?] [? that ?]
[? my ?] [? characters ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Does your experiences suggest
that nothing's changed?
BOISJOLY: No, I don't agree
that nothing has changed.
It's gotten a lot worse.
In the last 30 years,
I have witnessed
an unbelievable
decline and open chasm
between the technical people
and the managerial side.
And that has
actually came about,
as I observed when I entered
the profession in 1960,
the think tank groups
were implementing
a program, which we used to call
internally as charm courses.
Those of us who didn't
attend them would call them
charm courses, and
what these courses were
were three to five day
concentrated courses that
showed management how to extract
the maximum amount of profit
from an organization,
regardless, and never
look at the consequences
to that organization,
or the people in
that organization,
or the decrease in morale,
and stuff like that.
And through that period of
time, from about 1960 through
the middle '70s, it just
became obvious, and just--
employees were no longer their
resource, precious resource.
And I referred to them
as a renewable resource,
and that's exactly what they
became, a source of labor
pool without any regard
to the humanisation.
And the chasm between
the technical people
and the managerial people opened
up much, much widely than it
was when I was first--
when I was first
there, there was--
I thought there was a purpose.
And the purpose was
towards putting out
a good product, a quality
product, a safe product,
on time, at a competitive
price, on a teamwork basis.
We used to always check
one another's work.
There is no checking
done, and hasn't
been done since approximately
1970, or even the late '60s.
Very-- I don't
know of any company
that has the technical people
check one another's work.
And so the interest
is very obvious.
The obvious interest is to
get something out the door
to get money back in.
Keep the pipeline filled.
Everybody at the top
smiles and is happy.
It's as simple as that.
I mean, that's
oversimplification,
but that's the bottom line.
MODERATOR: I have a
follow on question
I'd like to ask about that.
Because one of the
things that we see--
the 273 students have been
interviewing companies
over the last few years.
And a lot of them have
made within the last,
oh, I should say,
mm, seven years,
they've made major changes.
And they've put in ombudsmen.
They've put in mechanisms
to be more responsive.
And even if we say that some
of that is window dressing,
I'd be interested to find out
how people see things going
because I've been
impressed that, at least
at some corporations, things
have gotten much better.
BOISJOLY: Yeah, I
subscribe to that.
I know of several corporations
with sure knowledge
that it is working.
It has been implemented
and is great.
But unfortunately,
at most of them,
they're in a learning process.
In all fairness,
first of all, you
have to give them credit
for first of all recognizing
that they have a problem.
Can't correct anything
unless you recognize
you have a problem,
and almost all of them
have recognized that.
Now, you have to
segregate those that
recognize they have a
problem and truly want
to fix it, and do something
about it versus those that
want to just superficially fix
it, and do something about it.
And I think we're
in that muddled area
right now, where some
are truly fixing,
and some aren't truly fixing.
Case in point, as a result of
the Presidential Commission
investigation, NASA was to
set up a reporting system
that people could
report problems
through the organization,
to a separate organization,
and remain totally autonomous,
and not be identified.
That system was
immediately destroyed
as several very diligent
people, used that system,
and found out that
their names were
blurted out all over the place.
It killed the effectiveness
of that system right out
of the chute, and that
system is just a front now.
And so you have
those, and you have
those that are
working moderately,
and you have those
that are working well.
And I have to say, and that's
why I've made it in my comment
from my observation,
that I believe
that most all the
companies recognize
they're in serious competitive
trouble in our world
marketplace, and productivity
is a rock-bottom low,
and that they have to
do something about it.
And they are putting
these in place.
And unfortunately, I don't
have any more insight than that
by observation.
Freada, you might have.
KLEIN: Well, I tend
to agree with you.
The mechanisms that companies
are putting in place,
in most cases, it
is window dressing.
It is too little, too late.
And the fundamental concept
of empowering employees
to speak up and to
use that information
to change decisions as well
as decision-making structures,
when it gets to that
critical point, that's
when companies back down.
So that certain kinds of
suggestions, certain kinds
of changes in
production processes,
in how business is
done, will be accepted
through those channels.
Things that question,
fundamentally,
the way the organization
is structured,
which may be causing some of the
problems, are not admissible.
I think just to be fair, there
is a larger context going on
here.
I mean, CEOs talk about
the pressure put on them
by their boards of directors,
by the shareholders
because of the power that the
Wall Street analysts wield,
and that they are held
only to short-term--
short-term earnings, which
leads to short-term thinking.
So I think we've got a much
more complicated problem here.
MODERATOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for Mr. Boisjoly
and a question for the panel.
Question for Mr. Boisjoly
is about your journal.
Could you describe when
you decided to start
writing a journal and why?
BOISJOLY: Yeah, I
never kept a journal.
I virtually never
documented anything,
except in the memo format
that I explained to you.
And what was happening
is that the problems were
getting so bad, that-- and
I was getting so afraid.
See, people think it was just
a low temperature problem.
I was afraid, after the summer
of 1985, to launch at all,
and that's why I wrote my memo.
And I started to
document everything
and, actually, filled
four of these spiral
wound notebooks with
my documentation.
I had a daily log because of
the fear of what was happening,
and that there
would be no record,
other than a verbal
record, to go back
to if something happened.
And that's really why I did it.
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
is, given that that
framework that you described
was destroyed, do
any of the panelists
have suggestions on how you
would create such a framework,
whether it was through
the professional engineers
or some other organization?
Given that it doesn't
work, apparently, now.
MARKS: You mean about
the particular status
of the engineer and--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, how the feedback
mechanism could be done,
could be made to work.
A whistle-blower
mechanism, however you
want to describe it, an
independent secure channel.
MODERATOR: Would you
like to start, Dave?
MARKS: When did you
stop beating your wife?
I guess, I don't totally
agree with Mr. Boisjoly.
I think that there are times
when engineering management
wants things that
are probably good,
and engineers don't
want to give it to them.
I mean, I see
numerous instances,
where engineers want
the technical challenge
in a new job of
redesigning something,
when, in fact, they have
something that works,
and that could
immediately be adapted.
But they want the
technical challenge.
So these terrible
engineering managers
are trying to get
more productivity,
and sometimes, they have
good reason to ask for it.
And the engineering
profession really wants
their sense of a
rewarding career, which
is to do reanalysis, to
start all over again,
and very often to
come up with things
that need to be tested again.
And they reinvent the wheel.
But then there's
another part of it,
which is the safety human
values thing, where,
in fact, engineering management
short-term philosophy is just
acting diametrically
opposed to public safety
and to employee rights.
So I-- this movement
of an engineer
from the technical to a
management line is never easy.
The people who tend to follow
it are often the more--
the more-- the less
technically happy, and the more
management oriented.
They see more
money to be gained,
and these sorts of things.
And they're under a lot of
pressures, not all of which
are bad pressures to begin with.
But coming back to your question
about what happens to the role
and to the status
of technologists.
I mean, it's no
surprise that the number
of people in the
United States who
want to go into technical
careers is going down.
We're finding the biggest
recruiter of our undergraduates
to be the big eight
accounting firms now,
who want the strong
analytic abilities,
and the ability to move
these people into finance.
That's where the action is.
That's where the
immediate money is.
That's where there is less--
one has to pay less of
a price for education
and get greater rewards.
What are we doing
to counter this?
I think, we haven't
given much recognition
to the importance of technology.
I don't see how that's
going to turn around.
It starts in the high schools.
Look at the level of science
and mathematical role models
and teachers in high school.
It is just simply not there.
So to a certain
extent, engineers
are defeating themselves because
they're not even bringing
people into the pipeline.
They're not making the
pipeline look attractive,
and this country
is paying for that.
MODERATOR: Jim, did you
want to speak to that--
MELCHER: Well, I
was going to pick up
on something that was
inherent to the two remarks.
And that is this feeling
that some of us have,
that the engineering culture
would be well transplanted
into the managerial
scheme of things.
That if engineers
turned into managers,
it might be good for management.
We put things in a
rather negative light.
Do you disagree with that?
BOISJOLY: Oh, no.
No, I think some of
the better managers
had come from the
engineering ranks.
But unfortunately, the pressures
of the business side of it
made them change
their allegiance.
But as far as--
one of the better-- best
managers at Morton-Thiokol,
for instance, was Al McDonald.
Al McDonald is the guy that
actually pulled the redesign
back together because
the other company
managers couldn't do it.
Right in the middle of the
redesign to return to flight,
they fell flat in their face.
And they had to actually call
on him to straighten it out,
and his engineering expertise
is what allowed him to do that.
And his-- the way he thought
allowed him to do that.
So if you can combine
the two, I think
you get an excellent result
for a person who really cares.
Person who has
product, and company,
and customer at the foremost
position and goal of his task.
I think you get a
terrific marriage,
when you do that type of thing.
MODERATOR: Oh, and did you want
to respond to that question?
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, Mr. Boisjoly,
you mentioned that
in a number of the ethical
decisions that you had to make,
the consequences of
them were severe.
Somebody's life was at risk.
And what my question is, is
how much do the consequences
play in your decision of whether
to go to do the ethical thing?
For a number of us, we'll
be in engineering field--
we'll be in engineering
fields that won't necessarily
have those kinds
of severe risks,
like perhaps you're
degrading an error
rate on an IBM [INAUDIBLE]
or something similar.
BOISJOLY: Well, yeah,
I mentioned some
of the more visible things.
But there were a
whole host of things
that I didn't mention that were
not only not life threatening,
they were not even product
threatening or anything
threatening period.
But they were just
the wrong thing to do.
And I don't mean that from
a judgmental standpoint.
For instance, there
was a part that was
stalled backwards on a missile.
It was a band, and it
was formed as a hoop.
And it was a very critical part.
It cost about $25.
They wanted to take that,
and reform it, and reverse
the hoop, and put it
back on the missile.
Well, it just so happens, I
was on the site at the time,
and I didn't want
them to do that.
I didn't even want to
spend the time running
an analysis showing
whether it was good or not.
It wasn't worth the hassle.
$25 is not worth ruining
$800,000 worth of equipment.
And they wanted to put it back
in stores and mark it scrap.
And I said, well, I don't--
to myself, I don't trust you.
Would you please let
me have the part?
I took the part folded
it in half, put it
on the ground, stepped on it.
It was totally
non-usable at that point.
They went absolutely wild
when I did that and said,
they were going to
file a grievance.
And they were
going to take me up
to all kinds of
management on this.
I said, fine, let's go.
Nothing ever came of that.
And so that was totally
non-threatening,
totally not anything,
and I've had many
of those types of things too.
It just-- it doesn't make sense
to risk multi-million dollar
systems for $25 and $30 pieces.
It's just not
worth fussing with.
And if you know there's
something wrong,
something's been
done wrong, just take
care of it on an inside issue.
That's all.
So I'm just the way
I am on everything.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I
apologize for being very late.
This wasn't
advertised, and I had
no idea this wonderful
meeting was going on.
But I'm glad I'm here anyway.
And I'd like to ask a
couple of questions.
The first one relates
to the statement
made that there's no point
in sacrificing yourself
if it can't make a difference.
And there have been a number
of statements we've heard,
which talk in
terms of trade-off.
Is it worth doing this in terms
of the consequences we'll get?
And one of my major problems
with the engineering
field as a whole
is the way in which
it tends to operate in
a consequentialist vein.
Philosophers today,
almost all of them,
would say the consequentialist
ways of thinking
are highly unsatisfactory.
And the community
of philosophers
has increasingly been
emphasizing issues of rights.
What is the right thing to
do, whatever the consequences?
If something is
truth, should I not
say that truth whatever will
happen to me as a result?
Should I simply shirk
that responsibility
because I don't think it
will make a difference?
Should one not go for justice,
whatever the consequences?
And I think that's
a fundamental point.
And I think it comes not just
into everyday decisions which
engineers make.
But I think it also comes into
the methods which engineers
use because
quantitative techniques,
by their definition,
are calculative,
and look at trade-offs,
and look at consequences,
and look at the best for
whatever the problem happens
to be.
Whereas perhaps a more
satisfactory approach
would be to say not
what is the best
under these certain constraints,
but what questions should we
be asking?
What is the best?
What is the right way
to do our analysis?
So I'd like you to
address this issue
of a consequentialist
way of thinking
and a right way of thinking.
BOISJOLY: Well, first of
all, if you acted that way
in a purist sense,
there would be knowing--
no one in the industry cranking
out anything for anybody.
Because the system is
so broken with regard
to those types of
things, in general,
that if everybody come
forth with every issue,
regardless of the
consequence, there'd
be nobody working because
they'd all be out of jobs.
I know that sounds very drastic,
but that's the way it is.
If everybody came through,
not to be around another day
to fight for the overall thing,
you'd have nobody working.
AUDIENCE: I beg to differ.
I think that the scenario is
one between people behaving
as machines, in
which they are using
standard techniques,
standard procedure,
slotted into some big
bureaucratic mechanism,
and people who are
taking responsibility
for the work which
they're doing.
BOISJOLY: Have you
worked in industry?
AUDIENCE: I certainly
have and I--
BOISJOLY: In the
aerospace industry?
AUDIENCE: Not in
aerospace industry,
but I've been a whistle-blower
in a very large scale case.
And so I have some experience
of these questions.
And I was quite satisfied
with my decision
to protest what I regarded as
an unethical form of computer
modeling, even though
it seemed to me that I
had no chance of doing
anything about it at that time.
And I was not satisfied
with doing my job,
and carrying on doing
computations, when
I found that that
was what I regarded
as an unethical,
immoral situation.
And I tried to influence
the people in the place
where I was working to try
and take this larger view.
I think one can, of
course, both do work,
and one can think about
it at the same time.
I think where engineering falls
down is the lack of thinking.
Furthermore, I think that
what we need educationally
is more training
in how to think.
I, frankly, despair as I
go through the corridors
here and see the advertisements
for this new ethics
course here, which ask
questions about what I regard
as somewhat obvious questions.
Should one make a
product that is unsafe?
Well, the answer to me is no.
I mean, that's as
far as it goes.
And perhaps there are some
things to discuss around that.
But that doesn't seem to be
the most important point.
The most important
point seems to be
what product should
we be making?
What methods should we be using?
What do our techniques imply?
What should they imply?
How should we do that
which is good and just?
And our basic
failure is a failure
to confront issues of justice.
And I think the profession
would be improved
if we started on that basis.
And I think good
work could still
be done within that framework.
BOISJOLY: Oh, I
agree, but aren't
you presupposing that the
person at the operational level,
low level, has the authority and
power to do what you just said?
It doesn't exist.
You're not given the freedoms
that you just mentioned.
In fact, the redesign, case in
point, on the shuttle program
was not designed by
the working engineer.
It was designed and
redesigned by the managers.
And it was up to the individual
engineers to make it work.
And so they didn't
even have the freedom
to come up with the ideas.
We had plenty of ideas.
We had 27 concepts that
were summarily dismissed.
So when you work in the
framework of not even being
allowed to do
something like that,
you don't have a prayer
out of the chute.
AUDIENCE: Ah, but if you start
from the position of insisting
on asking these
questions, you can empower
yourself to do these things.
If as a group, we
all forced ourselves
to do what we thought
was ethically correct,
and go for those
larger issues, we
would be able to
have some influence.
One of the things which made me
despair the most where I worked
was how the majority of
the other technical people
just went and did
what they were told.
And I often had
subversive little tours
around the floor I worked
on and said to people, look,
if only all of us
discussed these issues
and made them known
to management,
then we would have an effect.
We shouldn't allow
ourselves to be machines.
We should be part of the
major decision apparatus.
BOISJOLY: OK, I made that point
in my presentation, that one
of the first things you should
do is go get [? colleagal ?]
support--
first, verbally,
then in writing.
And so I guess I'm agreeing.
MODERATOR: I think we have
another question over here.
AUDIENCE: Well, I don't have a
question about the most recent
exchange from [? Bellsley ?]
[? rise ?] [? and speak ?]
as a [INAUDIBLE] [? for that ?]
[? heated exchange ?]
[? and no ?] [? elation ?]
for our society or what is
happening to the
use of technology.
[? Close their eyes ?]
[INAUDIBLE] Nevertheless,
the compelling evidence
is that [? in the years ?]
and technology have been helping
people for their humane needs,
not for their problems
short-term or long-term
for their humane needs.
Now, let me provide some
of the evidence that
lead to this conclusion.
More people go to school
today then ever before.
And they do that only in
technologically advanced
society.
More people live longer
today then ever before.
And they do so only with
technologically advanced
society.
[INAUDIBLE] [? accidents ?]
[INAUDIBLE] all
the technological
activity that you
have, over the past 80 or 90
years, as we are going down
[INAUDIBLE].
And if all the products
that those managers,
you referred to, were produced
without caring about people
or the dangers as the
whole system you need to be
[INAUDIBLE] by some of the
people that think it's falling
apart, then all of us would
have been killed everyday.
[? Matter of fact, ?] we use
the electric outlet, or our car,
or our toaster, or whatever we
use to make [? our weapons. ?]
More people go to school
today than ever before
in technologically
advanced society.
And that's a humane thing.
More people live in their home
without being sick and hungry,
and they do so
because of technology.
So I'm not saying that
things are perfect.
And there's always lots
of room for improvement.
And engineers, especially
engineers from MIT,
and scientists, and social
scientists, and economists,
and others should always
be working to improve.
But it's a serious
mistake, a serious mistake,
to say that because
of technology,
we have become [? idly ?]
[? humane ?] or that people
that are [? ahead, ?] on
top of our industries,
don't care about [INAUDIBLE].
The evidence simply is not
that because if you looked
at the [INAUDIBLE] [? and the ?]
industries around the world,
you can find any
[? deterrences ?] from other
companies [INAUDIBLE]
Or [? look ?] [? at the ?]
alternatives [? when people ?]
suffer in Sudan, Ethiopia,
or India, or Southeast Asia.
But they don't have
any technology.
They don't have any
of these industries.
Then the evidence would be
overwhelming about the benefits
that we derive from technology.
So it's not technology
that is at fault. It's not
our managers.
It is that we are not perfect as
human beings like [INAUDIBLE]..
We recognize the evidence that
they shouldn't get [? after ?]
[INAUDIBLE] and the other guy
he was distressed [INAUDIBLE]
but after a while
they [INAUDIBLE]..
So the point that I want
to make is the following,
I know no engineers,
whether in management,
or at the lower [? echelon, ?]
who willingly and knowingly
proceed with doing
something that
will be destructive to society.
Maybe, there is a [INAUDIBLE]
area in which [INAUDIBLE]
the other person is absolutely
[? certain ?] [INAUDIBLE]
and sometimes one person comes
out who's a [? judgment ?] one
way, and other
times, another way,
but not because they do
not care about society.
As an engineer, I
refuse to accept
that there are, in general,
not the exceptions,
engineers who simply
don't care because they
are managers [INAUDIBLE].
BOISJOLY: Yeah, I
guess only one comment,
and I agree with a significant
part of what you say.
But in another sense, I
disagree because how can you
explain the total destruction of
the work ethic in this country,
if you don't lay it at the feet
of the people who are charged
with running the
corporate structure that's
responsible for doing this.
We are no longer, as
the United States,
able to compete in the
world economy because
of this situation.
They've focused on
short-term profits
at the almost total
exclusion of everything else.
And then they are
responsible for that.
I've seen it in my own industry.
I watched it happened.
And I agree with you.
To a person, nobody openly
wants somebody to get killed.
Nobody openly plans
on something failing.
I agree with you.
But they, at the top,
never go down on the floor,
and kick the tires,
and find out what's
going on at the low level.
And it's not all their
fault, with regard
to what they make
the decisions on,
because the corollary to that is
that the bad news gets filtered
out so badly on the way up
that they get the impression
that everything is well.
And in 27 years,
I've never understood
why a CEO, if he did not have
the time because of pressing
needs at his level, did
not find a confidante
to go down, and kick
the tires for him,
and report back to him or her.
And they've never done that.
And I've never understood
that philosophy
because their companies,
generally, are coming down
around their necks.
And they don't
even know about it.
We are not competing
in the world economy,
not because we don't have the
talent, not because we don't
have the people,
or the technology,
we do not have work productivity
within that framework anymore.
And that's the
unfortunate consequence
of what has happened.
And so I just wanted to
interject that part of it.
AUDIENCE: I told [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
MODERATOR: I think
we're going to have
to end because we're 15 minutes,
actually, over our time.
I would hope that
you would come to--
those of you who
are in 273, Roger
will be in class on Wednesday.
And those of you
who are not, could
come on Tuesday to [? E25111 ?]
and have further discussion,
at 1:00, and have further
discussion on these issues.
[APPLAUSE]